a tragic image from the southern border
reveals the grim reality facing many
Central American migrants who make the
dangerous journey we warn you the photo
you're about to see is disturbing
it shows a young father and his 23 month
old daughter who died trying to cross
the Rio Grande in South Texas they were
found in shallow water a few hundred
yards from where they tried to cross the
girl is still clinging to her father's
neck Omar Villafranca is outside a
border facility in Clint Texas Omar what
do we know about this father and his
child
well good morning the father asked her
Alberto Martinez Ramirez and his family
had traveled from El Salvador and they
were hoping to claim asylum in the US
and they had actually been around the
border for a while when they decided on
Sunday to try to cross the Rio Grande
she says her husband and daughter made
it across on the first attempt but when
he tried to go back for his wife the
toddler tried to follow and fell into
the water and again I want to warn you
this picture is tough to look at she
says Martinez grabbed the toddler but
the two were swept away by the current
and they could not get out now this
tragic stories comes as we are learning
more about the migrant children who were
being held in government facilities like
the one behind me it's worth noting that
100 children were returned here
yesterday after more than 300 had been
removed after reports came out that they
were living in absolutely horrible
conditions CBP says they have less than
1,000 out of company children in custody
and they're using this facility again to
help streamline the transfer of the
migrant children to the
apartment of Health and Human Services
now lawyers who inspected the facility
last week told us that they talked to
children who said that they were still
hungry they weren't able to shower or
have access to soap that often and off
also they were sleeping on the hard
concrete floors but a CBP official told
us and I want to quote this I personally
don't believe these allegations gale it
is very tough to look at that picture
that picture says a lot thank you very
much
Omar